termino la espera en perú el país conoce
finalmente de boca de las autoridades el
nombre de su presidente
el maestro izquierdista pedro castillo
fue proclamado ganador este lunes por el
jurado nacional de elecciones y el
júbilo estalló frente a la sede de
campaña de perú libre
[Aplausos]
castillo aprovechó su primer
pronunciamiento para dirigirse
directamente a su rival keiko fujimori
[Música]
me voy
no podíamos más no retrasen
lo decía
el país
a tan sólo 44 mil votos separaron a
castillo de fujimori en la segunda
vuelta a pesar de haber contabilizado la
totalidad de los sufragios el resultado
oficial se retrasó durante semanas por
los recursos legales de keiko fujimori
que pretendían anular algunas papeletas
por un presunto fraude del que jamás se
ofrecieron pruebas contundentes
el lunes la hija del encarcelado ex
presidente alberto fujimori reconoció su
derrota pero prometió movilizar a sus
partidarios voy a reconocer los
resultados porque es lo que manda la ley
y la constitución que he jurado defender
[Música]
la verdad va a terminar de salir a la
luz de todas maneras pedro castillo de
51 años asumirá la presidencia para el
periodo 2021 2026 con un discurso
profundamente reformista sus propuestas
incluyen la redacción de una nueva carta
magna la proclamación de castillo se yo
a ocho días de la posición prevista para
el 28 de julio día en que expira el
mandato del presidente interino
francisco sagasti y en el que perú
conmemora el bicentenario de su
independencia